questa la tecnico perché ogni volta che
fai da te ne ha cassato il giro una
pacca
no no se fu paura di questo dolore
[Musica]
ciao ragazzi benvenuti all'interno di
una puntata di cucina buttata oggi non
siamo all'interno degli studios di casa
mia perché sono all'interno di una
cucina di un'altra persona una persona
con la quale a breve preparerò una
lasagna
chef bruno barbieri lo sai che stanno
con me tv matrix cioè da oggi sorso
conosco il kung fu esatta il suo
cucinare ok perfetto la prima lezione da
una cucina mi arriva una cipolla intanto
pulisce la cipolla
intanto lo si fa con quel coltello li
seppellisce un ospe luchino perché è
questo ma non solo dov'è la sammartino
siano strutture come questo che
figuraccia chef quinto dall'altra parte
e forza di certo se voi dopo vedi che ti
viene però poi questa che più diretta ma
chi
può dire che lei pelato la complicanza
intanto di riparava essere pulito si
chiama bull
era brutto oggi questo coltello e primi
quell'altro e adesso mi fai una bruna
il suo numero questo
nella pole nella borsa tagli così se
vole tagli così che sta facendo
l'inverso
ok così poi tagli così vai
metti l'anima se niente fosse
julien a occhi chiusi di mela collo è
pazzo
[Musica]
ho mai scelto di fare una regata a
baciarsi bravi non possa annunciare al
globo che il burrone a
tagliare prepariamo una lasagna mezz'ora
di noi sa bene
che cosa si ma nelle nomine da sangue io
parlo della ricetta che ho visto fare in
famiglia ci va la lasagna all'uovo
decadenti una versione detto uova uovo e
farina poi ceva il ragù che cioè la
besciamella si ci si si io me l'accordo
perché è molto buona persona io un po
mezz'ora su fare burro farina cioè
quella specie di cosa che si chiama
rubra cosa del genere poi ci aggiungi
latte è permesso
si può fare anche parmigiano anche ci
stanno ci sta anche la borsarella dentro
se no è nel senso per migliorare o
signoria nel senso no no no no no che
schifo la consorella posso dire serve
fare la pasta meno è il sale il sale non
serve weimar
ma d'occhio possono allora no no ti
spiego guarda ci fa cosi ok giri intorno
così vedi
[Musica]
ma che ti dà il suo appoggio fatta con
una mano sola
poveri così bravo più sbatti luogo
miglio viene la pasta quando lava
impastare possiamo farlo allora prima in
una ciotolina parte no
una bella pasta già presa al
supermercato è abominio vero perché se
vengo secondi da questa cosa qui
no e probabile domanda se vi sia
forchetta e ci dai di mano ci si sporca
una mano sola che cosa fai nella vita
basta scrivere
ma è un terzo grado cuciniamo cioè nel
senso ha detto la polizia che quando ti
ferma ti senti già uno spacciatore di
eroina
se mi sporgo da anni per sporchi perché
c'è le mani tutte sport per ora nuovo ma
che troppo unisciti le mani così
[Musica]
sembriamo 2 ed efficienti
adesso nel bagno apre il rubinetto e ti
lavi le mani sostituiamo nel frattempo
l'impasto ma che sostituiamo di questo o
due minuti nel bagno non un'ora e un
quarto si impasta solo con questa parte
della mano di fare come fanno le storici
dai bianca però così stiamo facendo
tutto quanto da soli capricorno che ne
esce
no di no no no no no no
così devi sempre avere questa parte qua
sempre qua mai così la tendenza succeda
nulla perché tu sembri non viene fante
dentro negozio di cristalleria
no canta mi fa diventare matto io
stasera vado a casa stasera fra mezz'ora
è
già pronta guarda ma indica le stelle
michelin ma chiedo perché stavo
scherzando su temi un velo di farina dai
vai così
ma se lo dici così stima che mi pu
prendiamo e la mettiamo là dentro ok
vai loro scendono carota cipolla dai una
bruma xvi alla grande chef prima che
faccio una cosa per me il becco cioè lo
sa intanto esposta la cipolla la lettura
h al sedano
[Musica]
uno spaccato a metà che si è sbarazzata
lo spaccato così così perché fai così
vedi e ti vengono fuori di cubetti così
era la pressione con kelly parte su c'è
veramente rischiamo ero capita basta
mettendo la stessa foga di prima e poi
no no così
allora bisogna dire una cosa ormai la
cucina è diventata di moda e tutti si
sentono come nel calcio che tutti si
sentono allenatori tutti si sentono
certo io no
le carote sono altri qualcosa
a occhio direi che dettaglia ma prima
fare no meta meta però una volta se
rompe da
ora è che quello spezzino la metà è così
che così non ti si vola perché se tu lo
fai così tantissimo realtà mazzini
chiarissimo
poi ci metti anche un po di burro burro
a muoviti a tagliare con chiede io devo
bucci puoi fare qualcosa tu per favore
vai e fai questo pezzo di grasso
insegne maestro taglio questa parte
grassa
ma tutto è perché arrotolata dalla
pancetta e quadrata la rotoli diventa
rotonde giunto grazie per una risposta
civile altri unite così te stata dettata
[Musica]
dai accesa
facendo
mi guardi dipende un po bisogna
accendere turisti perché montano al
contrario perché questo qui da solo
l'hanno girato e pedofi bisogni todo un
livello di un certo tipo no facciamo
come a scuola questa è la tecnico perché
ogni volta che fare con una pacca
sì però non era solo e lo so vorrei come
dio comanda
basta basta basta basta punisce tutto
[Musica]
scottex un qualcosa non c'è niente ma
biferi sotto scorta dopo che hai fatto
sudare sede perché era dato cipolla e
lancetta puoi aggiungere la carne tutta
così
no io c'ho sempre ci incazziamo
all'improvviso
[Musica]
il tegame non va messo giù le mani
no fai così ci dà il lavoro e buona
recando io possa toccare
il mio lo sai perché si bagna col vino
bianco
e possa alzare un po il tinge la carne
con noi dopo radu ti viene nero e
capelli solamente una questione estetica
sì sì giusto si forma in cucina si
mangia con gli occhi
ma siamo ancora a questo step cioè se
continuiamo così
che cosa ci va il concentrato di
pomodoro questi metti un popolo
controlli perché questo lo fa diventare
troppo rosso e non deve diventare troppo
rosso questa è una punteggiatura è
diventata cioè punto a capo dentro alle
buche conosceva adesso ma il brodo bravo
posso fare una domanda non vengono
parlato ho avuto tutto in tutto tra
audio so che la ricetta vera richiede
il latte ma alla fine come non piace
cell sanziona linate ci va e va beh non
mi c'è perché ci va al latte il colore
questo punto poco per togliere l'acidità
del concentrato di pomodoro che tu hai
messo io posso dirlo cosa è onesta non
lo sapevo
ad oggi almeno non l'ho visto la ricetta
prima che cosa dopo quando vai a casa ti
regala uno di questi così impari dopo a
farla mangiare quando io ero alla scuola
di ghiera precisano le sa questo pre
facevano prendere un pezzettino di carta
bagnata e mi facevano pulire intorno
questo perché qua si brucia un po più
sotto ai professori e ti fanno pulire
qualcosa di non parlare male di
produzione della squadra prepariamoci
per la besciamella
becham elsa chi l'aveva ambientata la
besciamella qualcuno crea molto tempo
libero no
doppio ma l'aver evitato il signor
besciamelle
il telefonino e guarda se non è così te
spacco questa è questa lo spacco sto
giro e modalità
pulisci bene a loro il regista sta
andando adesso non toccarlo più non devi
più toccarlo devi fare la besciamella il
latte il burro la farina la noce moscata
il sale una foglia di
vedi qua vedi qua la prendo subito una
loro ma loro a loro
perché perché la esista la io divento
matto
possa trovare un cambio un change no
devo farla quando parla come ti ha
insegnato tua madre jumbe chemin
preparano già adesso avendo meno hai
fatto il figo fatto il blue
fire voglio vedere se lo scaf m'incazzo
c'è un bug però lo chef ancora c'erano
questi allora fai la cosa metti supporto
5 tegame
devi farlo sciogliere prima però 99 dai
miei sogni alto anche da www quattro
militari cola dai per favore
non c'è la loro inventati da
metterci tutto questo dentro non stai
bruciando il burro poi la loro quando si
mette detto si fa una piccola è certo il
latte bolle metti il ru metti la farina
sì ho fatto ancora commuovono mette un
po di brodo li mettono tutto tutto
se sei fortunato è beccato barbieri
trai nemmeno un buonissimo
[Musica]
per portal di istallare che mi sembra
troppo salato ti ho detto che la davis
al azami di nuovo il sorriso come
l'inizio santo ci siamo il raduno nave
bellissimo questa bellissima primo
quello di lancio non avremo incazzarsi
certo effetto
va beh
[Musica]
ho capito perché la sentivo sanata
perché c'è il sorriso
non mi basta liga che cos'è la storica
mangia colore vi prego dove a
tutta questa pasta che non riuscirai a
tirarle da un botto solo e allora perché
la prendi tutto perché intanto da taglio
la metà di un po meno della metà tra le
opportunità nelle verdure escono si
spacca mi anche i coltelli che dopo è
[Musica]
e abbiamo questa è che
non sai neanche italiani la fa
a riadattarsi
piano piedi che c'è un verso che è
questo se tu devi fare così
così e cosà la reggina è questo vedi che
ritorna tonda sopra ok bagna il
mattarello con un po di farina mai
toccare la pasta ha pensato il
mattarello
allora io torno fra dieci minuti se
torno è infatti una cassata ti prendi
una pacca 15 a posto di aiutare con la
mano non dovevamo andare di là non al
tar la vedi che si sta asciugando allora
prendi un altro po di queste fai così
se andando troppo il latte fra un po ci
prendi da qua cosi gli iniqui e te la
metti così non la devi toccare comunque
libico ti metti le dita no no no no no
no
così
così poi mai così voi che la faccia
allungare fino alla in fondo a rischiamo
un bravo è fatto un buon lavoro a tutto
no
[Musica]
facciamo quella cafonata nel terrore
attivissimo non l'avevo capito che
facevamo una cosa più [ __ ] sono
intanto in burro a questi
[Musica]
è logorato fuori era lo specchio quella
perché se come marzullo fai domande dai
verbali e preferì volte 10 bastonate che
se paragonato al martullo salutiamo
marzullo non essere un po ingenuo chef
bruno voi ma quadrata cosa un'altra semi
celo celo quanti strati non ci vanno
sinistra che molte voci registrate che
ci hanno
quindi perso cioè non c'erano gli strati
io ho fatto un passo indietro e di
vista fa rispettare
[Musica]
ma
io non ho capito scienza veramente bruno
voi
stiamo affatto questi stampini non lo so
perché non ho parlato ma non è un
thriller che alla fine scopro
l'assassino con cosa tolgo quella
lasagna dal alla mamma mia sveglia però
l'affare con eleganza garanzia dell'età
voilà di sf bagnare dappertutto la
tristezza c'è un disastro ma non mi sono
mosso
quindi uno stampo ok
per toccare 8 lug carne perché questo
quadro ha trovato così
cosa è successo che l'italiano alla vita
giusta per più bello fuck fuck parliamo
in italiano
ci vuoi vedere così non devi fare casino
adesso è
concederti sono alcuni dati contenuti
nella medicina dove ci
penserà meno hai fatto una figuraccia
avrei fatto una figuraccia sera vero per
un momento no no no no no no no io
rispondo dov'è il parmigiano tiamina
vero l'ho fatto ma come
lo togliamo dobbiamo fare gli strati mai
detto negli strati che non c'erano
perché allora abbiamo fatto questi
quadrati me lo vuoi spiegare ok mette la
besciamella il mit innovation miti mi
fai anche spendere
la nostra
parte nostra mettilo bene
no no no no no io questo stress pa è
adesso in congo io una vita orrenda un
po superficiale ma non ho visto punto
dimesso è poco
quanto scott possiamo parlarne lo 0 4
ore per fare 4 st mulas per andare al
centro la sento questo vorrei sentire
questo mentre si lavora allora scelta
perché ci abbiamo un'altra ricetta di
fare lo stesso massima male sta
riempendo proprio tutto tutto tutto no
faccio quello che mi pare bel lavoro
complimenti al che roba che viene fuori
bravo
volevo solo pulire manca pure certo come
la queue di me quel 2 l'intoppo prima di
mettere in forno togliamo la carta
stagnola mettiamo un anno cibo lui vanno
nel forno quella che abbiamo fatto una
robina carina adesso messo detto così
come dargli una forma
se no si aprono poi se si apra anche un
po un pannello un po fiore un assaggino
meritatissimo magari ha lasciato
in tutto questo poi abbiamo comunque non
solo questa ricetta abbiamo una seconda
ricetta che potete trovare qui sotto per
concludere questo pranzo medicale esatta
che abbiamo fatto da tempo esattamente
se volete vedere come finisco
definitivamente all'ospedale è capito
fate un kit per scorso comunque devo
dirti un guru che se veramente
terapeutico
perché io sono arrivato oggi quadrano
una settimana di lavoro pesantissima ero
abbastanza carico
dopo un paio d'ore sto già bene perché
ho scaricato i miei nervi occorre però a
me lo dire la ci siamo molto divertiti
attenzioni il ragazzo c'è una buona mano
bisogna cambiargli il cervellino che è
quello un po piccoli però il resto devo
essere sincero io ero fatto un'idea
avete comunque per me c'è quartieri era
proprio capito ma invece comunque noti
l'uomo un essere umano per cui capita a
volte è vero che non bisogna importare
di ritiro ritiro io avevo fatto un idea
era quella che pensavo che eri molto
molto simpatico intelligente e che anche
quando ti incazzi in realtà c'è del
brillante dietro a questa la taglia
morale che possiamo mangiare smettere di
stare quanto la società dire una roba sì
che io ho già visto ai visi toccato
filiere non sei incazzato quindi penso
che siamo garçon prendi un pennello
o detto un pennello e che questo qui lo
scorso gennaio secolo del burro rete gay
passino
un cucchiaio inventati qualcosa o no e
marta attacca il re di burro
non premi burro cosi e fai così ok non
faccio lo faccio lo so fare era così lo
voglio fare io lo darei stato tutto
infatti lo sto facendo molto
bene che viene giù ma non fare una
pagliacciata fai le cose consenso è mai
caduto leggero
buche chiarino questo caso basta coi
cambia colore non li ammazza questo qui
da quattro anni
[Risate]
sparite una trivella
bastard hotel cà non mi piace per niente
la trovo una cafonata invece io penso ke
tu hai fatto una cosa carina e di questo
però questo non ho quest'anno poi
prenderlo perché abbiamo sono stato
picchiato attenzione che questo è il
nero non si torna indietro e appunto
dove a tocchi tocchi è ma che devo far
male no per carità possiamo continuare
il fai così e poi fai un disegno scarab
o tre nel corso dei datori dai o
fa cagare
ormai non può più fare mina insieme allo
chef bruno voi per favore io l'ho
piacere che esca fuori
quindi questo pulito e vivai sopra così
adesso te la fai da te bravo a mary
quant
che
fu paura di questo dolore
che gli arrivi il capolavoro
[Musica]
allora in camera ok mi presento ragazzi
la lasagna
mi presento che vorrei che il dritto
fare camera con avviene come delicatezza
grazie
non sa fa
come
[Musica]
sto cercando un nuovo cuoco per la mia
brigata di cucina
ufficialmente davanti a tutti dico buru
vuoi lavorare nella mia brigata certo è
un onore ma col potere grazie
no
[Applauso]
[Musica]
chef a questo punto il grembiule di shaq
guardie gb
ci pigliamo un altro paio di stelle
saliamo quali più questo qui me lo fai
salire di prezzo così me lo vendo un
domani e sto a posto ok grazie qua se
vendi questo 4 è già finito di lavorare
ma nel mondo della cucina io ho finito
l'altro ieri era ora